[Musik]
es sind dramatische szenen aus china die
nicht nur jeden hundefreund ans herz
gehen dieser kleine süße hunde ist
gefangen auf diesem steilen abhang
offenbar hat das tier große angst es
laut um hilfe beim spielen ist das tier
wohl aus versehen in abhang
heruntergerutscht klammert sich mit
seinen pfoten an die felswand da der
besitzer den hund nicht retten kann geht
er einfach überlässt den hund seinem
schicksal
touristen bemerkten das kleine weiße
fellknäuel auf den felsen rufen die
feuerwehr mit einem seil lässt sich ein
retter dann die felsen hinunter zu dem
hund und kann ihn in sicherheit bringen
unfassbar vom hundebesitzer fehlt
weiterhin jede spur
mehrere touristen aber bieten sich
spontan an den kleinen weißen hund zu
adoptieren
[Musik]